de l' embauche par la junte malienne de
mercenaires qui viennent essentiellement
sécuriser leurs intérêts économiques et
la junte elle-même c'est ça la réalité
de ce que nous voyons
c'est l'une des causes de la rupture
entre paris et bamako la présence du
groupe wagner sur le terrain réputé
proche du kremlin selon la france
environ un millier de mercenaires
seraient déployés au mali et il aurait
d'autre objectif que celui de ramener la
paix dans le pays le wagner c'est une
stratégie de président de prédation
d'exactions on voit bien ce qui se passe
en république centrafricaine et surtout
de notre point de vue c'est ça ça
représente un vrai danger pour les
forces armées maliennes celle entrave à
la montée en puissance et la
restructuration des forces armées
maliennes qui a été qui a été engagée
depuis début 2013 wagner a été
identifiée depuis 2014 dans différentes
zones de conflit où la russie a des
intérêts stratégiques soutien aux
séparatistes pro russes dans le donbass
reconquête du territoire perdu par
bachar al assad en syrie livraisons
d'armes et combats avec l'armée du
maréchal haftar en libye sécurité du
président maduro au venezuela formation
de la garde présidentielle et de l'armée
en centrafrique ou encore répression des
manifestations anti el béchir au soudan
la liste est longue le groupe est
présent dans une dizaine de pays en
échange il obtient le droit d'extraire
de l'or du gaz du pétrole ou des
diamants une armée privée de mercenaires
russes mais aussi étrangers désormais
dans le viseur de l'onu et de plusieurs
ong qu'il accuse de torture d'exécutions
et de viols sur des civils
au mali les autorités réfutent la
présence de mercenaires sur leur
territoire selon eux des russes seraient
bel et bien présents issus des forces
régulières ce serait des instructeurs
engagés dans le cadre d'une coopération
d'état à état pour lutter contre les
djihadistes venus pourtant début février
la dîmière poutine lui-même n'a pas
démenti la présence de mercenaires
russes malines mais il réfute tout lien
de l'état russe avec les sociétés
privées opérant sur le territoire